the joker gives actors the chance to
choose scenery like no other character
but his true appeal is how much of his
backstory remains shrouded in mystery
the only things crazier than the Joker
are the fan theories his cinematic
escapades have inspired here's a fan
theory that has been making the rounds
lately
Joaquin Phoenix isn't playing the Joker
in Joker at least not the Joker we all
know and love
for starters Phoenix is playing a
character named Arthur Fleck we've heard
Joker's name as Jack Napier before most
notably in Tim Burton's Batman
Jack Jack is dead my friend but he's
never had a 100% canonical identity and
Arthur Fleck is a new one frankly it
sounds like a red herring mr. Fleck is
also several decades older than the boy
who would become Batman this has caused
fans to speculate that Phoenix's Arthur
Fleck is not the real Joker but his
clownish criminal predecessor who
inspires the true Joker years later
Joaquin Phoenix's Joker isn't part of
the DC EU and is operating as more of an
else worlds tale which honestly means
this could go any number of ways maybe
Batman won't actually be battling his
arch nemesis until the Joker is in the
70s or perhaps Gotham is such a wacky
place that the psychopathic criminal
clown is immortal which has been hinted
at in the comics it sounds crazy right
well that's the Joker for you just take
a look at some of these other fan
theories about the Clown Prince of Crime
to prove one thing no matter how insane
the Joker is on the screen the fans can
get even insane err most fan theories
about the Joker Center on Heath Ledger's
performance in The Dark Knight this is
no surprise for a few reasons
Ledger's brilliant work was graced with
Oscar gold The Dark Knight was a
milestone event in American popular
culture and Christopher Nolan's
ambiguity about Joker's origins invites
fans to fill in the blanks what
skaars because the dark night can be
seen as a thinly veiled commentary on
the war on terror one of the most
popular theories is that the Joker was a
Special Forces soldier who suffered a
mental breakdown given Nolan's
deliberately realistic approach this
theory has merit after all it's not like
this Joker learned about firearms and
explosives just from watching the
Outdoor Channel but some fans who
believe Joker is an ex-soldier have
taken this theory to its logical next
level what if the Joker has PTSD such a
scenarios troubling to be honest but
before you dismiss this as pure fan
fiction consider Bane's class warfare in
The Dark Knight Rises released just
after the time of Occupy Wall Street is
it really a stretch to say that Nolan
imagined the Joker is a war veteran
wreaking vengeance on the society that
left him to die comedian Patton Oswalt
disagrees with the PTSD idea while he's
best known for his stand-up comedy
specials and voice work Oswalt is also a
pretty keen observer of superhero
stories he is an adherent of the Joker a
Special Forces soldier school of fan
theorizing but has added his own unique
twist in a lengthy Facebook post
published just two months shy of the
film's tenth anniversary
Oswalt wrote I just re-watched the Dark
Knight and another wrinkle came to mind
about the Joker what if he's not only
ex-military
but ex-military intelligence
specifically interrogation he seems to
be very good at the kind of Mike curry
that sustained professional
interrogation requires never start with
the head the victim gets all fuzzy he
can't feel the neck
see lots of fans seem to like the way
Oswald thinks the post has received over
17,000 reactions while Nolan has never
answered the fan theorizing and likely
never will the Joker as a military
interrogator Theory has given fans
plenty to mull over in a post popular
enough to receive some major media
coverage
reddit user general Z proposed that the
Joker was actually the hero of the Dark
Knight I thought my jokes were bad
according to this theory before Joker
showed up Gotham was so infected with
organized crime and corrupt officials
that the city turned to a masked
vigilante to save them then the redditor
rights along comes the Joker and by the
end of a very short time almost all
organized crime was eliminated many
corrupt officials were imprisoned or
dead in the cities vigilante even went
into hiding this was all part of Joker's
masterfully executed plan well when you
look at it like that
maybe Joker wasn't so bad let's not blow
is out of proportion but what about the
boats Joker was literally tempting
prisoners and pedestrians to blow each
other up
turns out the redditor has an answer for
that too as the Joker quote proved that
there was good even in the most
supposedly despicable of Gotham's
inmates that's a pretty generous reading
of his motivations but what is
undeniable is that by the end of the
Dark Knight Gotham's criminal underbelly
is destroyed all it took was a few
sticks of dynamite the murder of
countless innocents and a city of
millions beset by terror gee Joker
thanks another theory that's been making
the rounds is that the Joker was a spy
what's the evidence for one Joker's
knowledge of Gotham's power hierarchy
demonstrates a background in
surveillance there's also the fact that
Joker can withstand and apply both
physical and psychological torture and
there's the fact that whether you
believed he was a hero or villain The
Joker does want to save Gotham by
rooting out the city's criminality and
corruption it's an interesting take
whether or not you buy it though the
most fascinating thing about this theory
is that it shows just how much fans want
Joker to be the good guy albeit in his
own homicidal psychopathic way thank
yous for my phone call before Deadpool
broke the fourth wall in his self-titled
debut the Joker did the same thing in
the Dark Knight at least according to
one popular fan theory while Joker
breaking the fourth wall has
occasionally happened in the comics he
has never done so on the big screen or
has he breaded user someone's freaking
out postulated that the Joker in the
Dark Knight knows he's in a movie
the redditor argues that most of Joker's
comedy is meant not for the characters
in the movie but for a hidden audience
us I'm gonna make this pencil disappear
this gives the Joker a characteristic
rarely associated with him namely sanity
you may notice a theme running through
these Joker theories they all
fundamentally change the characters arc
and consequently the meaning of the
movie but what about a theory that
doesn't require any such drastic
retconning
Reddit user dork Knight 52 noticed that
the Joker a big fan of mass murder
doesn't kill anyone in through Swain's
party for Harvey Dent why the Joker
arrived at Bruce's party with one goal
to kill Harvey Dent who he thought was
Batman when Batman arrives and dives out
the window to rescue Rachel Dawes Joker
leaves thinking Harvey just jumped to
his death later in the film after Harvey
claims to be batman gotham's district
attorney has carted off in a paddy wagon
with a police escort we're led to
believe this is Batman's plan to lure
out the Joker but what if it was the
Joker's plan to lure out Batman
if Batman doesn't show that means he
really is dent when Batman does arrive
the Joker's master plan changes he no
longer wants to kill Gotham's White
Knight but corrupt him
you die now we're talking
what if Jared Leto's Joker was actually
Jason Todd this theory has been dancing
in fans Minds ever since it was first
postulated around the time Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice was released in
the comics Jason Todd was the post Dick
Grayson Robin until he was beaten and
blown up by the Joker the DC EU has
indicated that Jason Todd's story would
be part of the cinematic canon with the
blown up boy wanders costume appearing
in BBS but when Jared Leto appeared
months later as a much younger Joker in
Suicide Squad
some fans wondered if this Joker could
be Jason Todd frankly while this theory
is interesting fans probably liked it
mainly because the alternative is so
unappealing letõs tatted-up
interpretation of the Joker his the
Joker yeah we'll take the highly
implausible convoluted theory
speaking of which technically this story
isn't from any of the Batman films but
it is so awesomely out there we had to
share it according to redditor but kids
a Fight Club could be read as an origin
story for the Joker
David Fincher and Christopher Nolan do
share similar aesthetics so it's
interesting to consider the theory
points out that just like Joker Edward
Norton's narrator boo spoiler alert is
also Brad Pitt's Tyler Durden as a manic
personality a gang of loyal minions and
is an agent of chaos rebelling against
the status quo you were looking for a
way to change your life you could not do
this on your own all the ways you wish
you could be that's me oh he also shoots
out his cheek giving himself a messed up
face who knows this may have been
Joker's last story about how he got his
scar as if Batman hadn't interrupted him
the appeal underlying this theory is
pretty simple what could be better than
one internet fan favorite film - of
course I am Jack's
complete lack of surprise what perhaps
the most exciting theory is the one that
has been staring us in the face this
whole time Batman and the Joker are
brothers according to this theory Thomas
and Martha Wayne had another child
before Bruce that was born with a mental
disorder and was confined to a
psychiatric hospital that child Thomas
Wayne jr. aka the Joker the comics have
danced with this idea for a while now
but fans have argued there are some
hints trapped in the dark night to
consider the famous interrogation scene
in which Joker goes to great lengths to
explain to Batman how he is a freak like
him this
establishes the to of symbolic brothers
but what if it's hinting that they're
literal brothers as well brothers don't
shake hands
brothers got a joker also says that when
the people of Gotham don't need Batman
anymore they'll cast him out like a
leper physically and psychologically
engaging in a sadistic game with his own
brother that's right up the Joker's
alley
this theory doesn't concern one Batman
movie but several of them the idea is
simple as soon as one Joker is gone he's
replaced by another if we're being
literal this is the only theory that is
100% true from a business perspective
Warner Brothers does more or less need a
new Joker in every incarnation of the
Batman franchise he may be crazy but the
dude is money while the Joker is
necessary from a financial and
entertainment perspective in our
universe what if in some strange
metatextual way he was also necessary
because the DC Universe itself needs a
joker
redditor gotta post fast argues this
while trying to create a correlation
between the Tim Burton and Joel
Schumacher Bat verse and Zack Snyder's
according to this theory when Jack
Nicholson's Joker died he was eventually
replaced by Jared Leto's thus the Burton
Schumacher Batman is the same one as the
DC EU batfleck vague sequels and soft
reboots are increasingly the norm in
Hollywood and composer Danny Elfman did
score films in both franchises bringing
back the Batman March for Justice League
did this be a hint that the DC films all
exist in one giant shared universe I
find that unlikely still this kind of
theory could play into the older version
of the Joker that Joaquin Phoenix is
stepping into so who knows anything is
possible in the bat first check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you